in May this year the ninth part of the
very successful Fast & Furious franchise
will be released the hype around the
action-packed movies which are more or
less about cars doesn't seem to stop at
least financially in an interview
leading actor Vin Diesel now revealed a
few details about the future of the
film's according to his own statement
the production of Fast and Furious 10
has already started in view of the
immense success of the series he even
went so far as to say that future
spin-offs are practically inevitable
diesel already gave a small foretaste at
the end of last month when he announced
a fast and furious with an all-female
cast in the interview he also mentioned
that Fast and Furious 10 might at least
be the end of the main movies and that
the final film will be released in two
parts if this is really true we will
probably find out after the release of
the ninth part on May 22nd 2020 last
week we already reported about a
possible Bambi remake this week the next
Disney classic is already in the line
for a remake according to the dis
Insider website lilo and Stitch will be
a live action and CGI mixed film and
will be set in Hawaii the 8th in Europe
movie lilo and Stitch is about a lonely
girl named lilo and the alien Stitch who
tries to hide more or less successfully
in the role of a dog both become friends
throughout the story and experience one
or the other adventure with each other
when the film was released in 2002 it
earned 273 million u.s. dollars on a 80
million dollar budget in the course of
time some sequels and spin-offs as well
as an own animated TV series were
created unfortunately there are
currently no concept pictures of how the
two could look like as live-action
characters anyway Disney doesn't seem to
want to stop making live-action remakes
from old classics in the foreseeable
future the fan community is rather split
in its opinion when the Disney Plus
production will be released is not yet
known after it was recently announced
that the shooting of the new Matrix
movie will start soon the first pictures
from the set have already been published
and the star of shooting has been
announced more or less officially but
will star actor Keanu Reeves be back in
his legendary outfit with a leather coat
and black sunglasses on the set he was
seen in his usual look of peered and
longer hair quite different it's the
case with Reef's colleague carrie-anne
moss who again embodies the role of
trinity because she looks quite similar
to back in the days besides the two
actors Reeves and lost there will also
be Jada Pinkett Smith as Nell be and
acting colleague Yaya up to Martina in
front of the camera How I Met Your
Mother star Neil Patrick Harris will
also be part of the cast the u.s. cinema
release of metrics for is on May 21st
2021 this search for a new director for
dr. strange too has finally come to an
end after the Marvel movie hadn't had a
director for almost a month a recent
report from Variety now suggests that
Marvel Studios is currently in
negotiations with Sammy Raimi many
people might know him as the director of
the 2002 spider-man movie with Tobey
Maguire and the leading role an official
statement that he will inherit the
previous director Scott Erickson is
still pending the only thing that is
certain so far is that leading actor
Benedict Cumberbatch will return as
Doctor Strange together with him
benedict wong and xu @ l @ u 4 will also
be back in front of the camera but
before Doctor Strange 2 will be released
on may 7th in 2021 the Marvel films
Black Widow the Eternals
and zhongshi and the legend of the ten
rings will be released in the cinemas
horror fans watch out 14 years after the
film adaptation of Silent Hill director
Christophe Gong has now announced
another adaptation but that's not all as
he also told Allison II that a film
version of fatal frame is planned but
first things first
Silent Hill is about a small town where
author Harry Mason wants to spend a
holiday with his daughter on the way
there however they are involved in a car
accident and when Mason regains
consciousness his daughter has
disappeared on his search for her he
gets to face a series of monsters and
creatures in the now not so sleepy small
town at least that's the story of the
first part of the video game but in 2006
film adaptation the plot is slightly
different there Rose
and her daughter Sharon make their way
to Silent Hill to get to the bottom of
Sharon's strange nightmares whether the
new movie is more oriented towards the
video game series or its predecessor is
not clear at the moment in fatal frame
however it's about a missing journalist
named ma fuyi he seems to have
disappeared in a huge villa while
searching for material for a new story
and his sister Miku is searching for him
there as you can imagine this story also
doesn't really work out in favor of the
protagonists regarding this project
director Gao only revealed that it will
take place in Japan and that he doesn't
want to miss the typical Japanese
haunted house setting unfortunately
there is no further information about
both projects at the moment
[Music]